[Music]
even back in the mid-90s Disney's logo
was sucking its own spire oh I come from
a land from a faraway place narration
that his son what fresh hell is this yes
every Disney movie from your childhood
was much more sexual than you remember
evidenced here by this lyric clearly
talking about all the wonderful ways in
Arabian night can be hotter than hot if
this all leads to HBO picking up an
option on game of lamps I'm totally in
casual animal abuse you oddly Jesus even
hand-drawn movies feel compelled to make
tardy and as part of their dialogue even
when it serves zero narrative purpose
the cave awful one funny story Cave of
Wonders was actually my nickname for my
college girl if you wanna make it hard
for posers and non worthy fools to enter
Weiss found out all rules like this for
anyone nearby to hear
why clarify the why of why you deny this
once like I struck a parrot with human
teeth bread was about to ask the same
question dog can we talk about this
laundry line for a second wouldn't you
need some sort of pulley system to get
the clothes out there instead of a
single peg did they just climb all the
way out there to hang their clothes
you're only in trouble if you get caught
and sometimes not even then just ask
Alex Rodriguez this guy is literally
swinging a kill sword a bread thief I
know they chopped off thieves hands here
now but straight-up murder does he do he
cocks his dad and he never realized
before how easy it is to accidentally
cut someone in half except she hasn't
hey Anakin Skywalker didn't have parents
either and look how he turned out gotta
eat to live gotta still to eat stealing
this man is clearly lying between the
nails so the joke kind of misses the
point kappa chattering all the Back to
the Future movies had come out by this
point but this film still wants to act
like having the villains land and poop
is neat fun new edgy you're hilarious
it's none of those things it's honestly
one of my least favorite things about
the Back to the Future movies how was it
the Fabrizio here isn't gonna that men
fall from the sky into his livelihood he
should literally give it about this here
oh I'm taken flawed hero does a random
act of kindness so we know he or she has
a heart of gold and our being a good
example for their monkey cliche on his
way to the palace glad these Rando
crowds positioners just have to be
saying their thoughts out loud but how
would we ever know what was going on I'm
not sending his sandals I'm sinning that
he can't make up his mind on appropriate
Footwear why is Raja holding a piece of
the heart undies fabric here when the
pants he took a chunk out of we're
obviously purple unless that's a piece
of fabric from a different section of
the underwear in which case I have a lot
of questions jasmine has been a prisoner
in a castle with only animal friends her
entire life and has three more days of
slight independence before being forced
to marry a man and continue to lose her
identity that's dark if I do marry I
want it to be for love this feels like a
conversation you'd have had way before
three days until the deadline Raja
this movie is way too Kinkaid all about
a tame king tiger the most trained
tigers alive in modern society still
nearly killed secret or roy or whoever I
can't remember which one point is Tigers
Jafar
my most trusted advisor Dick Cheney
[Music]
hello after being hypnotized I see a red
eyed zombie and if you can do this to
people as powerful as the Sultan why do
you need Genie powers you were already
in charge of an entire country I love
how she put on sackcloth but left on the
ginormous gold earrings even Mariah
Carey would be embarrassed to wear
Jasmine takes an apple from the fender
gives it to a little kid and walks away
look I know she grew up sheltered in the
palace but she for sure knows that the
market isn't free Aladdin grabs the
sword hands it to Jasmine who hides it
behind her back but as they walk away
it's completely missing honestly there
are so many animation continuity errors
in this thing let's just throw on an
extra 20 sins and move on
have the gods extend him an invitation
but you merely saw his image in a king
hourglass how the guards know who to
look for this is some nuclear level yada
yada hey man
the director said let's have the monkey
end up with two apples even though he
had three just a minute ago and eight to
begin with because then people will be
so confused they won't know if he's an
asshole or not did you trust me what do
you trust me why the would she dude
jasmine somehow neither sees nor hears
this despite being within a few feet of
it death by big painting this it's dark
man you forgot about it because Robin
Williams shows up and everything gets
hilarious for a while but it's nearly as
dark as the dark parts of Hunchback I'd
remove all the sins right here if
instead of comforting Jasmine Toronto
just bitter in half like a regular tiger
would I know we're going for a dour mood
setting establishing shot here but
panning down over the change I am
shocked they built a prison cell with
this highest ceiling and mostly this is
just a chain storage facility since all
these rafter chains are doing nothing
but harmlessly dangling why did you far
have to cosplay and sell Adhan on the
cave quest via this fake old prisoner
gun why not just tell him you'll reduce
his sentence if he does it then be too
far when you ask or just zap it with the
snake staff and mind-control him wait
didn't the cat say earlier that so why
is a boo able to waltz in there too
before you claim that it's because he's
an animal there are a couple problems
with that monkey business first
he certainly counts when he sets off a
booby trap by touching the loot and
second if animals didn't matter why
couldn't you Favre just sin and yaw go
in the first place and let him swoop in
and grab the lamp oh it's kind of a
little bitch this is a golden chicken
this is a golden Stay Puft Marshmallow
Man peeking out from behind a cauldron
just FYI do you think he knows where
he's or she no one will be seated during
the house' big is this goddamn cave
anyway portion of the movie good thing
they spent 60 seconds by friending the
ex machina carpet before they came in
here huh let's just say that for this
section a luck dragon started a
coincidence cherub in a threesome with
an advantage angel and this scene is
their baby giving you the finger
honestly with a boulder this big I'm
calling bullsh bun carpet wriggling free
with its own strength now
no whoever he was he's long gone with
that lamp oh come on
you can cartoon physics the silly stuff
of the important plot points to a boo
really has somewhere to store a lamp
that big
yeah and monkeys might fly out of my
butt and then have lamps fly out of
their butts ten thousand years will give
you a such a crick in the neck for you
very much even in 1992 the Ed Sullivan
Show reference probably missed its
audience by about 30 years what's next
at Groucho Marx reference from the dead
setting aside that all three of these
rules are very plot convenient no never
mind send that but also what do you mean
you don't like doing it doesn't that
mean that you've done it even though you
just said it was a rule that you
couldn't do it there's a difference
between not wanting to do something and
not being allowed to and if I learned
anything from Fifty Shades of Grey that
difference must be negotiated during
this contract phase you don't though
just use the snake staff and hypnotize
him or her or both of them honestly
don't understand you far at all he's
like Leonardo DiCaprio on a mile-long
yacht lying on a bed of cash surrounded
by naked models getting a handjob from
the literal hand of God looking up into
the sky and saying something that's
missing in my life I love the way a foul
little mind would hey we'll handle the
obvious puns around here mister you win
although the princess to marry me hold
up serious in question time right a good
you fart do this instead of just mind
controlling Jasmine herself she also oh
that's racist now try your best to stay
calm brush up yes Sunday so long
literally everyone is taken in him by
this fucking song and dance and
ultimately Aladdin didn't need a genie
he just needed a Broadway production
then come and meet
this may be just employed the use of the
word coterie and I'm almost ready to
take a sin off for not dumbing down its
lyrics but then again I did have to do
research on what it meant so here's a
sin for you and another five for your
spectacular coterie to share amongst
each other wait what I'm an excellent
judge of character
excellent nah remember the knot joke
that was super 90s we should bring it
back I'm serious
you remind me of someone I met in the
marketplace I've never understood why
Aladdin doesn't come clean here it's
obvious they hit it off before and he
doesn't need her to think he's a prince
to marry her he actually is a prince the
movie makes it seem like he thinks he
needs to impress her but doesn't he
already have plenty of evidence to the
contrary you trust me the Latin suit is
clearly a full sleeve and secured at the
wrists when he reaches for jasmine his
arms bare little-known trivia this is
because it's not actually Aladdin's arm
this shot was a pickup and it's the arm
of a stagehand named Kevin who stood in
for the day he was wearing a Metallica
tank top but the producers didn't want
to pony up to fix it digitally this is
so dangerous this magic carpet is
turning this cloud into the poop emoji
and now you will never be able to unsee
it you are welcome that being said I
love the a whole new world sequence and
it gave me chills even while I was
watching it for sin purposes two cents
off what's worse this movie's obsession
with apples or Aladdin's constant use of
his King elbow as an Apple delivery
device this flower is clearly on
Jasmine's left in the real world and in
the water considering that this is the
second time this movie has forgotten how
to mirror correctly I'm adding five sins
in the hopes it will cause the movie to
take some time to reflect
I sometimes dress as a commoner um to
escape the pressures of Palace life so
he steals food all the time and lies
more than an American politician are we
sure this guy's the hero wow that's
definitely murder the only reason it's
not is because Jeannie saved his life
but these guys don't know that's gonna
happen I told you that it was darker
than you remembered coincidental rubbing
is a bad screenwriting technique but it
would make an excellent name for a
massage parlor I can't help you unless
you make a wish except you did earlier
and sure maybe he was tricking you then
but still you did it so you could do it
now and really the fact that you
manufacture a wish to do it might be
more of an asshole new Jafar spot in the
lamp right now is just lazy writing what
if they find out I'm not really a prince
sorry if I'm repeating myself here
Who am I kidding I'm not sorry but you
are really
the wish wasn't to look like a prince it
was to be a prince you aren't a fraud
you took a shortcut that's just working
smarter not harder
I can't wish you free Aladdin has
another wish before needing to free the
genie
damn you writers for driving a wish
shape wedge between the best buds just
to build tension he never used that
second wish genie just made an
assumption then you will cower before
all the mind-controlling magic you were
doing earlier I thought you already were
a sorcerer let's go none of you should
have any clue what direction to go to
get there though just FYI on these need
to see you reduce to this jasmine is
there a way that we could really
emphasize that too far is an asshole you
can have him literally put Jasmine in
Chains
what if you also spit on her hmm we're
close what if he did it all about eating
an apple Daryl you're a genius now
improve secant seems necessary hot damn
this guy is the most observant guy ever
how many times do I have to kill you um
want which you never even personally
attempted even though you've had plenty
of opportunities get points like here
for instance instead of creating a
barrier with these swords maybe just
impale him with them you could have even
used the same pun well no problem you
still got one wish left
just say the word and you're a prince
again dammit movie he's not just the con
artist formerly known as a prince he's
still a prince wish away why did it get
reversed two wishes have expiration
dates he has two wishes Aladdin was
unconscious when genie decided to save
him this is bull okay so genie is free
now but you still got powers right he's
still doing a bunch of magic can he just
help Aladdin as a favor instead of it
having to be a wish on this Dave Hoff
the princess shall marry whoever she
deems worthy well that was easy
too bad he couldn't have done that back
in the beginning of the movie then
Aladdin could have just used his wishes
on something more important like
infinite genies
hell no it will give 110 percent
[Music]
sometimes you feel so you're just all
right Sparky here's the deal what is
your position on breast implants
maniacal laugh I choose you Aladdin you
choo choo choose me